في اهم اجتماعي للحلفاء والداعمين لبلاده
في حربها ضد روسيا قمه النيتو في ليتوانيا
يظهر الرئيس الاوكراني انزعاجا مما قال
انه عدم تحديد اطار زمني لانضمام اوكرانيا
الى النيتو واصفا ذلك بالامر العبثي وغير
المسبوق كلام منزلنسكي جاء رغم حديث قريب
للرئيس الامريكي يفهم منه عدم نيه الحلف
الذهاب في هذا الاتجاه اذ ربط بايدن
انضمام اوكرانيا للنيتو بانتهاء الحرب كي
لا يكون الحلف مضطرا لخوض مواجهه مباشره
مع روسيا
ما يحدث الان يضاف الى ما يوصف بنقاط
الخلاف او عدم الوفاق بين كييفو واشنطن
فقبل وقت قريب نقلت صحيفه بوليتيكو عن
مسؤولين امريكيين حديثهم عن تباين متزايد
خلف الكواليس بين الولايات المتحده
واوكرانيا قالت الصحيفه النكيه لا تلقي
بالا لنصائح واشنطن العسكريه بشان اهداف
الحرب وكيفيه موعد نهايتها منها حاله
استنزاف القوات الاوكرانيه لق في معركه
باخموت شرقا المدينه التي لا تتمتع باهميه
استراتيجيه من وجهه نظر المسؤولين
الامريكيين كذلك الطموح الاوكراني
باستعاده شبه جزيره القرم لم يكن محل
ترحيب امريكي لا بل ان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي شكك في قدره القوات الاوكرانيه
على استعاده شبه الجزيره بعد مرور عقد على
الوجود الروسي فيها استهداف او تخريب خط
نوردسترين للغاز الروسي نحو اوروبا كان
نقطه توتر بين واشنطن
تقييم استخباراتي الى ان مجموعه مؤيده
لاوكرانيا هي من استهدفت خط الغاز الروسي
خليفه العام الماضي
ورغم استمرار حزم المساعدات العسكريه
الامريكيه نحو اوكرانيا تتزايد طلبات كييف
بالحصول على اسلحه متنوعه بشكل مستمر من
صواريخ الى منظومه الباتريوت وصولا الى
الذخائر العنقوديه ومقاتلات اف 16 الامر
الذي دفع مسؤولين امريكيين الى ابداء تدمر
من حاله الطلب المستمره من كييف لتلك
الاسلحه ومن عدم اظهار الرئيس الاوكراني
اي امتنان مقابل هذا الدعم وفق حديث وسائل
اعلام امريكيه اخيرا اشار مسؤولون غربيون
الى الوضع الداخلي في اوكرانيا وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن تحدث عن
ضروره استمرار الاوكرانيين في اصلاح الجيش
وترسيخ الديمقراطيه كما اشار مسؤولون
اخرون الى قضايا فساد وجهت اصابع الاتهام
فيها الى مسؤولين اوكرانيين رفيعي المستوى
منهم وزير الدفاع وحكام ومقاطعات